JOINING US TONIGHT FOR THE
HOUR TAMMY BRUCE AND ROB
SMITH.
BUT FIRST PRESIDENT TRUMP
PARENT POWER REVOLUTION.
HERE HE IS LAST WEEK IN WHAT I
THOUGHT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT POLICY STATEMENTS OF
HIS PRESIDENCY.
>> IF SCHOOLS DO NOT REOPEN
THE FUNDING SHOULD GO TO
PARENTS TO SEND THEIR CHILD TO
PUBLIC PRIVATE CHARTER
RELIGIOUS OR HOMESCHOOL OF
THEIR CHOICE.
THE KEY WORD BEING CHOICE.
IF THE SCHOOL IS CLOSED, THE
MONEY SHOULD FOLLOW THE
STUDENT SO THE PARENTS AND
FAMILIES ARE IN CONTROL OF
THEIR OWN DECISIONS.
I WOULD LIKE THE MONEY TO GO
TO THE PARENTS OF THE STUDENT.
>> I’VE BEEN ARGUING FOR THIS
FOR YEARS.
HERE’S WHAT I WROTE IN MY BOOK
MORE HUMAN.
THE GOVERNMENT SCHOOL MONOPOLY
REQUIRED STANDARDIZATION AND A
FACTORY APPROACH.
WE NEED A COMPLETELY OPEN,
LOCAL MARKETPLACE FOR SCHOOL,
TEACHERS, ENTREPRENEURS,
GROUPS OF PARENTS MUST BE
PERMITTED TO SET UP SCHOOLS
FREE OF BUREAUCRATIC
RESTRICTIONS AND HASSLE.
TODAY IS BECOMING A REALITY.
ALL BECAUSE THE TEACHER UNION
AND THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
BUREAUCRATS HAVE OVERPLAYED
THEIR HAND.
AS I PUT IT IN A TWEET, AFTER
LAST SUNDAY’S SHOW, THE
GOVERNMENT SCHOOL MONOPOLY IS
DYING.
SUICIDE, THANKS TO TEACHER
UNION, SCHOOL BOARDS REFUSING
TO GIVE PARENTS WHAT THEY
WANT.
MICRO SCHOOLS, HOME SCHOOLING,
IT’S ALL HAPPENING.
NEXT STEP FEDERAL SCHOOL
VOUCHERS.
MY SCHOOL MONEY BACK.
WE’VE LAID OUT THE EVIDENCE.
WEEK AFTER WEEK, THE SCIENCE
SAYS REOPEN SCHOOLS.
CHILDREN ARE FAR LESS LIKELY
TO GET THE VIRUS, SPREAD THE
VIRUS, SUFFER FROM THE VIRUS,
WHILE THEY ARE SUFFERING
MASSIVELY FROM NOT BEING AT
SCHOOL BUT THE EXACT SAME
PEOPLE WHO LECTURE US ABOUT
FOLLOWING THE DATA WHO CALL
YOU A SCIENCE DENIER IF YOU
DISAGREE WITH A SINGLE ASPECT
OF THEIR EXTREME ENVIRONMENTAL
AGENDA WHILE THEY ARE THE
DENIERS NOW, KEEPING SCHOOLS
CLOSED DESPITE ALL THE
EVIDENCE IS NOT JUST
UNNECESSARY FOR CONTROLLING
THE VIRUS BUT ACTIVELY HARMFUL
TO OUR CHILDREN CHILDREN.
NOW I TRIED TO BE OPEN-MINDED,
THE BUREAUCRATIC SCHOOL
CLOSURE.
GRADE ARE JUST COVERING THEIR
YOU KNOW WHAT.
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS, THEIR
OVERCAUTIOUS GOING ON ABOUT
SAFETY BEING THEIR TOP
PRIORITY EVEN THOUGH KEEPING
KIDS AWAY FROM SCHOOL IS NOT
SAFE, IT’S DANGEROUS, BUT WHEN
YOU SEE THINGS LIKE UNITED
TEACHERS OF LOS ANGELES AND
THEIR SCHOOL CLOSURE DEMAND
ADDING MEDICARE FOR ALL,
DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND THE
MORATORIUM ON CHARTER SCHOOLS,
THE OREGON EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION DEMANDING MORE
FROM THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS EVEN
BE STOPPED FROM OFFERING
DISTANCE-LEARNING, IN NORTH
CAROLINA LOCAL AFFILIATE
DEMANDING MORE FROM UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE AND INCOME SUPPORT
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WHAT HAS ANY OF THIS GOT TO DO
WITH SLOWING THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS?
NOTHING.
THE SCHOOL CLOSURES ARE NOT
ABOUT HELP, THERE ABOUT
POWER.
A CYNICAL TRICK TO BOOST THE
POWER OF PROBABLY THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE INSTITUTION IN
AMERICA, THE TEACHER UNION AND
IT’S NOT JUST CYNICAL, IT’S
CORRUPT.
THE POLITICIANS CAVING TO THE
TEACHER UNION ON SCHOOL
CLOSURES THAT ARE JUST DOING
THE BIDDING OF THEIR DONORS,
MORE THAN $200 MILLION OVER
THE PAST THREE DECADES.
WITH DEMOCRATS THE
INSTITUTIONAL CORRUPTION GOES
ALL THE WAY TO THE TOP.
JOE BIDEN, THROUGHOUT HIS
CORRUPT CAREER BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR BY THE TEACHER UNION
INCLUDING NEARLY $2 MILLION
SINCE 2018 FROM JUST ONE OF
THEM THEM.
HERE’S WHAT THE UNION GOT IN
RETURN.
>> YOU DON’T JUST HAVE A
PARTNER IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> NO PRIVATELY FUNDED CHARTER
SCHOOL WILL RECEIVE A PENNY OF
FEDERAL MONEY.
NONE.
>> IN HIS PLATFORM, BIDEN
PLEDGING TO KILL A WASHINGTON
D.C. SCHOOL CHOICE PROGRAM
THAT HELPS POOR KIDS GO TO
COLLEGE OVER 90% OF THEM BLACK
AND HISPANIC.
BIDEN’S CORRUPT SCHEME TO
ATTACK THE VERY SCHOOL THAT
HELPS POOR KIDS AND BLACK KIDS
THE MOST IS RACIST AND EVIL.
IT ALONE MAKES HIM UNFIT TO BE
PRESIDENT.
PARENTS CAN SEE THROUGH ALL
THE BS.
THEY’VE HAD ENOUGH AND THEY’RE
NOT TAKING IT ANYMORE.
TWO WEEKS AGO WE LAUNCHED OUR
CAMPAIGN.
>> IF YOU ARE CHILD SCHOOL
WON’T OPEN THIS FALL, DEMAND
YOUR MONEY BACK SO YOU CAN
FIND AN ALTERNATIVE.
IT’S YOUR CHILD, IT’S YOUR TAX
DOLLARS.
WHY SHOULD YOU PAY FOR SERVICE
YOU NOT GETTING.
THAT’S OUR NEW CAMPAIGN.
REOPEN SCHOOLS OR GIVE ME MY
SCHOOL MONEY BACK.
NOW, PARENTS ALL ACROSS
AMERICA ARE RISING UP IN THIS
REVOLUTION TO SMASH THE
GOVERNMENT SCHOOL MONOPOLY.
LAST WEEK JORDAN SECULAR TOLD
US THAT HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES
HAD CONTACTED THEM ABOUT SUING
CLOSURE DISTRICT.
HERE’S THE MAP AS OF FRIDAY.
OVER 1000 PEOPLE FROM 46
STATES AND D.C., IF YOU WANT
TO JOIN AND GO TO AC
LJ.ORG/HEALTH.
THE SCALE AND PACE OF THIS IS
SHOCKING TO THE COMPLACENT
EDUCATION ESTABLISHMENT.
IN THIS ACCOUNT SHARED BY
BETHANY MANDEL WITHIN A 48.
, THOUSANDS OF PARENTS
SCRAMBLED TO PUT TOGETHER
HOMESCHOOLING GROUPS.
THERE ARE REPORTS OF FAMILIES
TEAMING UP TO RECRUIT TEACHERS
AND FORM PANDEMIC PODS SO
STUDENTS WON’T GO MONTHS
WITHOUT A REAL EDUCATION.
OF COURSE THE SNOOTY ELITISTS
TRIED TO PRETEND IT’S ALL
ABOUT RICH WHITE PARENTS, IT’S
RACIST TO WANT TO EDUCATE YOUR
KIDS NOW APPARENTLY.
HOW DISGUSTING.
FOR YEARS, BLACK PARENTS HAVE
BEEN IN THE VANGUARD OF THE
SCHOOL CHOICE MOVEMENT AS
THOMAS SOLD IN HIS DOCUMENT
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THEIR
ENEMY.
AS HE PUT IT, SCHOOLS EXIST
FOR THE EDUCATION OF CHILDREN,
NOT TO PROVIDE IRONCLAD JOBS
FOR TEACHERS, BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN UNIONS, MONOPOLIES
FOR EDUCATIONAL BUREAUCRACY, A
GUARANTEED MARKET FOR TEACHERS
COLLEGE DEGREE, OR A CAPTIVE
AUDIENCE FOR INDUCTOR AND A
HEIRS.
THE LEFT SAYS POOR PARENTS
CAN’T HANDLE SCHOOL CHOICE.
HOW PATRONIZING.
ONE OF THE MOST INSPIRING
SITES OF MY LIFE WAS SEEN
PARENTS IN ONE OF THE WORLD’S
WORST SLUMS IN NIGERIA GET
TOGETHER TO FUND A LOW-COST
PRIVATE SCHOOL PAYING JUST
SENSE TO SEND THEIR KIDS THERE
BECAUSE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SCHOOL WAS FAILING THEIR
KIDS.
PRIVATE SCHOOLS FOR THE POOR
IS A PHENOMENON SWEEPING THE
DEVELOPING WORLD.
AND NOW, HERE IN AMERICA, THE
ALTERNATIVES TO GOVERNMENT
SCHOOLS ARE BECOMING MORE AND
MORE AFFORDABLE.
THERE ARE MANY ORGANIZATIONS
READY TO HELP.
WE’LL PUT THEM OUT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
BECAUSE THE COST OF THESE IS
FALLING ALL THE TIME, A
FEDERAL SCHOOL VOUCHER IN THE
LOW THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS WOULD
ENABLE MILLIONS OF PARENTS TO
ESCAPE THE CLUTCHES OF THE
GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS AND THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED THIS WEEK THAT HE
WANTED IN THE RELIEF BILL.
GUESS WHO’S STANDING IN THE
WAY OF THAT.
UNBELIEVABLY, IT’S MITCH
MCCONNELL AND STEVE MNUNCHIN.
RIGHT NOW, PLANNING TO GIVE
$70 BILLION TO SCHOOL
BUREAUCRATS INCLUDING THOSE
WHO WON’T EVEN OPEN SCHOOLS.
THEY THINK THIS IS SMART
POLITICS BEFORE AN ELECTION.
NO.
SCHOOL BOARDS DON’T VOTE.
PARENTS DO.
GIVE THE MONEY DIRECTLY TO
THEM.
JUST LIKE THE PRESIDENT WANTS.
MAKE IT A REDLINE FOR THE NEXT
RELIEF BILL.
LET’S GET IT DONE.
LET’S PUT POWER IN PARENTS
HANDS.
LET’S PUT OUR CHILDREN FIRST.
VOTES KILL OFF FOR GOOD THE
POWER OF THE EDUCATIONAL
ESTABLISHMENT, WHO SCHOOLS